let's just say
one morning a guy who
used to live in california now lives in
austin texas
wakes up and he's bored out of his mind
okay and this happens to him quite a lot
and he wakes up and he says you know
what
i've been in the most competitive space
for a long time
and i'm competing with everybody and the
company i built is called tesla
right and you know kind of gone to space
i've blown up a few things here and
there but i've been pretty successful
during the time in a limited budget
and it's kind of cool i started a
company called the boring company
what about if i decided to go and
screw with everybody and start a
smartphone company
could i compete with everybody else out
there my name is elon musk
huh okay so i've heard a lot of
uh you know could uh could one of these
companies start a smartphone especially
tesla tesla makes batteries could tesla
make an incredible smartphone with great
battery
and my initial thought is yeah of course
don't why would i ever doubt
and him with startup of course he could
probably pull it off
but the other hand uh is
this smartphone space especially in the
top
you know bit of of of of market share as
we were describing earlier
is ruthlessly competitive now of course
the auto industry was ruthlessly
competitive before tesla came along but
tesla came along with a new technology
that it's going to take them
years to catch up to and i don't know if
there is a
new technology that smartphone makers
aren't considering or haven't already
tried to start working on
that someone could just leap in and
dominate at
smartphones are trying all kinds of
stuff
you know when you look at the new
highest end phones it does seem very
consistent the same high-end screens and
cameras and everything
but i was just talking about the folding
phones the swiveling phones
the new battery tech we see all this
wireless tech all this stuff is getting
better at a very high rate and if you're
going to just jump in there
there's another company called red that
i'm a big fan of that makes incredible
cameras
and they decided they were going to jump
in and make a smartphone a couple years
ago
and i thought okay yeah red could make a
phone and their advantage would be the
camera
and they made a terrible phone and it
died
before the year was over so i
i don't know that you can just jump in
and immediately start competing for the
top end of market share you can make
something interesting
but i think i think it would be pretty
tough see the difference between
red and tesla would be
no one knows the founder of red except
for people in the world
everybody knows the founder of tesla and
tesla likes to do things when you tell
him he can't do it you know the guy elon
you know him you've interviewed him
before you've been to his plant before
you've seen what he's done
and he prefers that he likes that and i
think in your interview you said what uh
f the number one car he posted in an
article he talked about it the number
four number one car where people switch
over to tesla is what a prius a twenty
four thousand dollar card that they
switch over to
the tesla and you ask them a question
whether you guys going to be able to
come out with a cheaper car and he said
maybe three years because
manufacturing being able to keep up with
orders etc etc
you know if you were to say ecosystem
wise
you know apple is pulling from their app
their imessage their other hardware
their phone
watch you just showed who has an
ecosystem to be able to pull into having
a phone would it be a tesla would it be
a facebook would it be an amazon
who would it be that has an additional
product already to say
here's what we already do we're going to
come up with a phone
and if you use us we're going to give
you an extra experience on dot dot dot
right yeah that is really interesting i
i so amazon did try
uh making a phone didn't go great but
you would think so amazon's got aws
they've got
the amazon store they've got their own
app store they've got amazon
music that's a good start that
you could kind of tie in i don't know if
anyone's compelled to switch
from their iphone because of amazon
music or something like that but if they
could make some
cool exclusives with the amazon.com
store
maybe that's something but i think what
i found is the most compelling reasons
to switch are actually
just great hardware so if you could make
a great
smartphone accessory and i don't know i
don't think a
tesla is gonna be that smartphone
accessory but if you can make a great
uh accessory that is amazing hardware
and works
best when you have your phone and not
the iphone
that becomes a reason to switch because
you know all of apple services are fine
imessage is fine apple's mail service is
fine
safari is fine i'm not you know looking
for a reason to switch web browser i can
use chrome on the iphone whatever but if
you have like
these incredible headphones and you need
to have
this phone to be able to use this
amazing headphone experience and apple
doesn't offer that
maybe that's a reason um but out of
today's
existing companies like you just
mentioned like tesla amazon
whoever hasn't made a phone facebook i
think even tried to make a phone and it
was also terrible
so it's clearly tough it's competitive
but uh
i think it would take some sort of a
missing link hardware type stuff